[Music]
let the battle begin
hi there it's senior editor Kevin Van
Ord standing in for reviewer Tyler Hicks
to tell you about heroes of the storm it
was only a matter of time
Blizzard has thrown down its hands in
the battle arena market heroes of the
storm is yet another example of the
quality we expect from developer
Blizzard ideas that have been explored
elsewhere are given a level of
refinement and accessibility that makes
the eventual golden result nigh
impossible to dislike as with similar
games two teams of five faced off with
the goal of destroying the opponent's
base unlike those games however the map
upon which teams faced off is not a near
carbon copy of maps from similar games
heroes of the storm features seven
unique maps with various secondary
objectives that can assist a team in
their siege of the enemy base each of
these secondary objectives serves to
create interesting movement and points
of conflict and helps prevent the game
from devolving into poke Wars or
stalemates where teams are too afraid to
engage with each other
one of heroes of the storms primary
draws is its cast of characters from
blizzards various franchises by gangs
assemble while these are essentially
recycled pre-existing characters heroes
of the storms character design still
greatly impress 'as Diablo offers his
signature red lightning breath as an
area of effects team fight ultimate
while Raynor may call in help from the
Hyperion battle cruiser to rain down
fire from above these characters bring
their own signature moves from their
franchises into the arena with them
while still sliding neatly into the
mould of a different genre while most
characters fit into the standard classes
of warrior assassin and support heroes
of the storm features a fourth
classification specialist specialists
all have mechanics unique to their
characters and don't really compare to
the other characters in the game abathur
may attach a symbiote to an allied unit
in order to launch his attacks from the
safety of his own base azmodan empowers
nearby minions
summoning a relative army all his own
the specialist characters offer an
entirely different perspective on heroes
of the storms gameplay as your
characters level up during a match you
choose how to customize your build
through leveling up various talents that
augment your characters skills there are
no items to buy in heroes of the storm
all your character customization is
handled solely by the talent system this
is the source of the game's primary
drawback two or three of the available
talents per level are gated behind a
hero mastery system it requires you to
play several games as the hero before
you're allowed to select some of the
more advanced masteries this cripples
character potential in quick match and
encourages players to grind for
experience in matches versus the less
capable AI in order to level up their
hero's mastery match length and heroes
of the storm is short relative to other
games in the genre rather than spending
an hour or longer hoping for a game to
finally come to an end
matches are often decisively ended
within 20 minutes if you wish to shine
individually you may not enjoy heroes of
the storm the game is very team centric
to the point that even experience is
shared across an entire team all players
on the same team are the same level
during a match an individual's power to
affect a match is limited grouping up is
essential to winning matches and
attempting any sort of heroic 1vs5 play
will likely be met with death
this serves to reduce the amount of
rampant toxicity the genres rather
notorious for bringing most gay men chat
experiences feature very few instances
of nasty epithets and with cross teen
chat disabled outright there's no
opportunity for insulting opponents the
environments animations and sounds of
combat all evoke a mental investment in
the action animations are simultaneously
flashy and elegant and ability
animations feature enough clarity that
it's rare to be confused about what
killed you from top to bottom heroes of
the storm is a must play for both mobile
players and Blizzard enthusiasts it
avoids stepping into the exact
footprints of the games that paved the
way for the genre and delivers a
beautifully graceful unique experience
with familiar characters and should you
not be a MOBA fan or a blizzard fan it's
still a fantastic casual competitive
game that offers untold hours of
enjoyment
leave with your lives
[Music]